[Music]
covid numbers
in the state of nevada are moving in a
downward trend but doctors say
it's not a sign of a positive trend just
yet
yeah brian the number of new cases today
was the lowest it's been in two weeks
but
experts say we could still see spikes
with the holidays ahead
sasha loftis joining us now live tonight
to explain
[Music]
denise and brian many are just really
happy to see our kovit 19 numbers
down slightly here in nevada but the
doctor i spoke with tonight
say now is not the time to let our guard
down
especially with christmas coming up it's
been nine months since kovit 19
completely changed our world people need
to take this serious
i think that we need to stop this lock
down stuff no matter how you feel about
pandemic precautions
experts say they're more important now
than ever this is not the time to get
fatigue
this is the time to double down after
weeks of climbing
our coronavirus numbers in nevada have
dropped in the past few days
with a 20.6 positivity rate reported on
thursday
but dr jonathan bhaktari says our
state's spot on the charts
is still concerning i think we're just
seeing
you know some of the fallout from all
the big gatherings over the holidays
and as that falls down we're coming back
to whatever
baseline we would have and as many plan
to travel and meet for
christmas it could ramp right back up
again which is why we all
have to do our part limited to the bare
essentials
and you don't need the cousin of the
cousin of the cousin or your best friend
to show up to your christmas party this
year well this holiday
might be one of our hardest those we
spoke with say
these efforts to get through it are
worth it to keep our loved ones safe
if you don't love yourself hopefully you
love some somebody in
in this world that you can you know
listen to the scientists
now i also asked dr bhaktari if this
drop in case numbers over the last few
weeks has anything to do with our
statewide pause
he said it's not likely as it's still
pretty soon to see
results from that he said as you heard
him mention it's more likely related to
just kind of a leveling off after that
spike immediately after thanksgiving
reporting live in las vegas tonight
sasha loftis 8 news now